it has been
i think more than a decade since you
were last a real housewife i know once a
real housewife always a real housewife
but
since you were on the show how did you
hear it was coming back
and why did you say you know what let's
try it again i was chatting on instagram
with andy cohen and he basically was
like you know what you think about doing
the show i say the show you know we were
just talking about the show and you
basically said let's chat like in a week
and talk about the show and then it just
happened
and then it just happened next thing you
knew cameras were following your every
move yeah
hi guys
was it kind of an instant yes it didn't
take much convincing um i had a
conversation with my kids because i was
like now that they're older like do you
guys want to be on tv you know do you
guys care if i do the show and they were
excited to do it you left the show after
season one and i feel like we never got
really an explanation on the show why
that happened so can you shed any light
on why you didn't return for season two
um scotty got a job working for the
bulls and we took our kids back to
chicago and went back to our house in
chicago and i just watched the show from
chicago
so you watched seasons two and three how
much in contact did you stay with the
women i've maintained my relationship
with lisa you know really good friends
we hang out all the time alexia we would
always text each other call each other
to check in
marisol i
recently that was one of those
relationships that we really
weren't close season one and so i've
gotten to know her a whole lot better
this season and
you know i've really enjoyed spending
time with her i think she's amazing so
it's you know it kind of it seemed very
natural for me to like be a part of this
band you and lisa did not overlap on the
show so how did you two link up we had a
lot of very good mutual friends so we'd
always attended the same parties dinner
parties birthday parties and stuff like
that so we were friends off the show
well we get a what feels like a pretty
tense moment in the trailer between the
two of you
stay out of it like you normally do what
leads to that moment why would did you
have that kind of snap with her because
you seem to be
on good terms oh no she's she's i love
her we're really good friends um
no i just feel like that conversation
was i had to get out my point and i she
just was trying to like control what i
was saying and really i was like no no
you always stay safe so you stay safe
and let me just get out my feelings
until
you know tell nicole how i feel
got it
you made the first season of real
housewives of miami from my
understanding not knowing it would be
real housewives it was kind of like a
social circle
social club
it was supposed to be a cooking show
right which is why every episode is
centered around a bizarre dinner party
with no explanation
um so stepping into it this time knowing
you were making real housewives did you
approach it any differently no i knew
that it was going to be
it was going to be challenging you know
but you know i was fine with it other
than making sure your kids were on board
with you doing this did you have
anything that was maybe holding back or
things that you might i don't know if i
want to open myself back up to people
being in my business i'm very open on
social media so you know i'm used to
that i was gonna say i feel like people
are gonna talk about you whether you are
saying something or not so you might as
well take the chance to say it i know i
feel like people just i say something
and they sometimes take it the wrong way
i don't know well
that's kind of where we start this
season and what the trailer was all
about you are larsa is the name on
everyone's lips did that surprise you or
did you expect it i kind of expected it
you know i kind of expected it i
i feel like you know i i never give my
side of the story i'm always the kind of
friend or you know whatever that doesn't
really give her side of the story and
this kind of gives me a chance to give
my side of the story so i was really
excited about that i'm trying to have
time for me to work out go shopping look
cute it's a lot of work i feel like you
have grown and evolved so much since we
first met you 10 years ago um how would
you say larsa 2021
is different
or the same as lars said 2011. i feel
like i'm older more mature
you know more confident i don't have a
husband i'm single so i've been
scrutinized so much in the last like
three years i'm like i might as well be
on reality because i'm taking a beating
in you know in real life i've achieved
so many things in three years all these
other women have had you know 40 some
years to work on their brands and for me
like i was playing house
and so now this is my chance to like you
know do the things that i'm passionate
about the charities i want to be
involved in and help grow
you know my the brands that i'm so
passionate about um so it i feel like it
was a good experience for me
yeah your life has been so much about
other people up until the last few years
where you've gotten to
take some time for larsa you mentioned
dating you re-entering the dating world
is a big topic of conversation on this
show
what are you looking for in a guy is
there something specific or are you just
having fun no i i feel like i'm better
with someone than i am alone i feel like
we'll see what are the three must-haves
for that oh okay so the three must-haves
would probably be i want a best friend
someone that's
you know i can hang out with all the
time and just like
not feel pressured to see him just be
like oh my god my best friend i can't
live without him
someone that's kind of funny and got a
good personality
um someone that's driven i feel like
it's successful because i do feel like
that attracts me i feel like i've always
liked guys that are like bosses it's
just something that i like
i'm attracted to
who doesn't like a
i mean i don't know i have friends that
literally date guys that are just really
you know like
really good looking guys that are not
really bosses and they just like them so
much
okay okay so i would i would say i would
take a guy that was a boss over a really
good looking guy i like that because
looks fade but drive can grow grow grow
um so you do want to get married again
it sounds like
i think so i think right next year i
should be married
okay we're putting it out in the
universe i mean why not but next year
i'm gonna hone in and like you know put
that energy out of what i want okay
season five of real housewives of miami
it seems that you and scotty have a
pretty good co-parenting relationship
and friendship how does he feel about
you going back on the show
um we had a conversation because he had
to sign off you know for the kids being
on the show
and
he was fine with it he was like you want
to be in the hot seat that's on you he's
just like that's on you all right the
other
actually there's a number of hot topics
about you that come up one that keeps
coming up is your body that larson her
face is different her boobs are bigger
her butts is even bigger
there's a lot of ass
just looking at me her but obviously fit
is fake so i thought her butt would be
like hard as bricks
but her body's
her butt actually feels good how do you
feel about that being such a point of
conversation and such a thing that
people keep going back to and honestly
making digs about i feel like you know
everyone should be comfortable in their
own skin as long as you feel good about
yourself i will praise you
and other women are not like that i feel
like other women just want because they
don't feel good about the way they look
they want to sit there and criticize how
someone else who looks way better than
you by the way so i don't know i feel
like that's not really my personality
i'm more of a girls girl like i'll never
tell someone they don't look good yeah
and i can read between the lines there
of who maybe you're referencing i mean
adriana's the one who
larsa is her favorite word it sounds
like that's what happens when you have
nothing else going on though when you
have nothing else going on you're going
to sit there and you're going to
criticize the person that's across from
you that's
building an empire that's
working on their family and their
friendships and their growth and then
other people are just bored and you know
pointing things then there's only fans
larsa
i love my only fans i mean it's just so
much fun how do your kids feel about you
having only fans
it's i'm literally posting the same
things i post on instagram stepping into
that first lunch did you have any idea
that this was gonna be such a hot button
issue for the other women
i had no clue it was going to be such a
hot topic with the girls you know what i
also feel like they live in a bubble in
miami they don't really know what's
going on in the rest of the world
sometimes when you judge things it's
because you're you're not as
knowledgeable about it
and that's kind of what happened on the
show well and i i think when you said i
make 10 grand a day
a lot of people
shut up
but think about it if you could do
something that was super easy at home
and text with people that literally all
they write you you know
you become friends with you know these
people i'm friends with the people my
you know my friends on only found i like
them i care about them i check in on
them is like the name of the platform
sounds like it's what keeps you there
like you like the interaction with these
people that's why you like to be on that
i mean it's fun it's really fun and i do
like the you know the one-on-one and
you know exclusive content things that i
wouldn't post on instagram where i'd be
like oh my god what if someone thinks
this i wouldn't care because it's like
if you're following me on only fans you
truly care about me it's not like i'm
one of you know what i mean even though
my subscription is free it's not like
i'm charging for my subscription so it's
funny that these girls would think it
would be so wild and like so why not
what do you then charge for oh it's just
like you know certain photos or direct
messages to me but like my content is is
free my subscription's free and your
content is pg-13
i mean it's pg 17 or 18. okay so it's
it's like r-rated but it's not
x-rated or no no no it's not yeah i mean
my kid my kids take my photos most of
the time just so you know
i love that insight do you think the
women are maybe jealous to an extent of
this life you've created for yourself
in the in between i mean i'm i'm living
my best life like i'm having so much fun
i'm at a great place i just wish that
you know women
empowered each other and made each other
feel good because honestly that's all i
do with everyone i love to help other
women and i love to see women winning
you know
but it's not always like that another
big focus for
adriana more specifically is your
one-time connection to the kardashian
family
larsa left miami with the mean of the
kardashians chandra out now she's back
in the group and trying to really regain
our friendship and trust you have said
your piece on this you have said you are
ready to move on and i just want to know
how you feel about it being brought up
when you've put it in the past and does
it affect your ability to feel like you
can move on honestly like kim and i are
in a good place i love them i love her i
wish nothing but you know great things
for them and i feel like they wish
nothing but great things for me
um so i don't know why adriana would say
that i think it was just something for
her you know she she likes to fight
she's one of those people that loves to
be in a cat fight she got her claws out
and i feel like that was just like an
easy dig at me but
i don't know i'm not going to let
someone else it's not in a great place
you know discredit all the work that
i've been doing on myself you left this
group of women come back with about as
big as kim kardashian's trying to become
the new king kardashian which you're
never gonna be
i'm looking forward to whenever that
moment airs so we can see how you
handled it and what you said back to her
because i think that will be interesting
i mean i will say i'm kind of out of
character because i feel like when
someone attacks me i don't know how to
like act sometimes i need to like tone
it down a tad bit but i'm just not used
to being attacked
welcome back
this show is going to be really good i
feel like just watching the first two
episodes i was like oh my god it starts
off with the bang it just like escalates
[Music]
thinking about everything you lived and
what we're about to see what are you
most excited for the fans to get to
experience or to relive yourself in
season four
um i feel like you know the
entrepreneur's side of myself just like
you know when i was on the first season
like i said i was i really was a
housewife i took care of scotty and the
children and now it's like a whole
different place in my life and on the
flip side is there anything that you're
bracing for impact for or that you're
gonna cringe watching back um i hope not
i don't know i'm not sure you know we
did a lot of filming i'm not sure if you
had to sum up season four with one word
what's the word drama filled
i'll take it a hyphenated drama filled
yeah just you know just
drama filled i don't know the season was
definitely
fun it was fun to shoot i had a great
time other people are focusing on all
the wrong things
you need to focus on all the right
things that make you happy and sometimes
people are not focused on things that
will give them you know happiness like
living a life of purpose will give you
happiness is there anything that's going
to shock the viewers about what plays
out
or that any maybe anything that shocked
you that you were like i did not see
that coming i think the whole season has
got a lot of those to be honest with you
i think the whole season is you know
it's a lot of good stuff alexia told me
that adriana is definitely the pot
stirrer of the season would you agree
with that she's like the weasel she's
like the weasel like the little brother
that just annoys you the entire time
you're at home she's definitely the
weasel of the crew all right i think
we've got to leave it at adriana's the
weasel of the crew because i don't think
we're going to top that sound bite larsa
yeah i think that's that's basically it
she texted me happy thanksgiving and i
was like happy thanksgiving you were
like yelling across the
like table at me like a lunatic and i
think people sometimes are you know
definitely that
[Music]